beaucoup jour jack chez la branche c'est
vrai évidemment quand je parle de drogue
via la boutique drôle bien savoir la
bullshit appel à grosses dents longues à
savoir l ecstasy lsd de toute cette
merde et aujourd'hui je peux enfin pour
cette charmante je vais 27 2e catégorie
j'ai renoncé à l'ecstasy je veux d abord
espèce de drogués var non je déconne
sérieusement vous aussi vous allez
pouvoir toucher et asie après cette
vidéo parce que c'était pas du film dont
ce fait d'un jeu complètement what the
fuck épileptique c'est comme si bob
l'eponge se retrouver au pays de mickey
et je monte son image mais 2 ng/ml
aujourd'hui ne vous accueille sur cetto
n'a pas du tout le monde sait ce quiz y
est gentil on se retrouve sur un jus
complètement what the fuck et je pense
que vous l'avez deviné un rien tchad à
cette superbe interface lorsqu'on lance
le jeu c'est complètement what the fuck
on a un chat qui clignent des yeux en se
léchant le menton honey yamanaka
courroux fait longtemps que j'ai pas
juste mais merde très très longtemps que
j'ai pas joué à ce truc et je peux merde
en gros le but du jeu où vous êtes un
petit nyan cat a perdu dans un monde
complètement what the fuck avec défendre
des toiles des oiseaux et secours volant
des deux poings avec un chapeau des
licornes là même le mec la licorne jeu
de la licorne pressants des prêts s'est
présentée précédemment bardon oui bien
sûr le mag
quand la musique commence vous allez
voir voilà fallait arriver à un truc
complètement ignoble des récompenses de
gauche bartoli for the big man
c'était que pas s'effacer s'avère
regarde c'est juste accolade entre
hannspree plus tard merde
prenez pour des conscience de ce que
l'industrie du jeu vidéo devient jesup
les messieurs dames jeu
[ __ ] la valette qui tremble comme pape
ait envie à l'ananas à peu un
vibromasseur actuellement généralement
jouer claval être posées sur les et du
coup bah ça c'est épique
bref on va tester les autres mauvais
mois de fuck waouh tailler une langue
qui a fait me faire une grosse des choix
de fuck un mec qui met découdra en
levant un vieux terme et plus what the
fuck c'est pas possible tu as le king et
les yankees pour l'amour
il ya lui qui veut aller les rejoindre
pour les sucer je sais pas mais what the
fuck un cochon avec un masque à gaz sur
un avion ou là où la houle à sa part
salma cacahuètes la dame ait commencé
voilà ça fait mal aux yeux je vous
promets que j'ai mal aux yeux comment on
peut en arriver à faire des choses
pareilles
oula oula ou alors là on a dû niveau là
je vous dirais que l'edge l'îcone de la
saucisse et du jambon bio le to qui
s'envole sur de musique un peu des pride
forcé d'évoquer de folie omg oh mon dieu
le sens inverse what the fuck watts deux
facteurs mais hoat de fuck mais c'est
quoi ce trait c'est pour tuer et
eneurope temps mais c'est impossible et
la bécane à l'appel du cerveau mais café
jeu et elle a blagué
j'ai un chien accroché un bifteck là va
pas être [ __ ] mais pourquoi maintenant
des frontières olalalala mais non mais
je me sens partir à chapiteaux
à bientôt tout le monde et pis